[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
y mom and if you're anything like me you
believe that a glass of wine at 8:00
p.m. makes you a better mom
so don't pour yourself a glass because
today we have a really special guest
again you might recognize him from last
wine pairing video we did
please welcome Christopher Webb our
fancy wine man hi hi welcome back I've
been just thrown on the floor so why
don't you tell the people who haven't
seen you before a little bit about
yourself as you said my name is
Christopher Webb I'm a saala
at a restaurant in Malibu and I my job
is essentially helping people find the
wine that they're going to enjoy with
their meal so the last pairing was you
know food and wine and I know that's
what you're used to doing older try some
abstract pairings so today we're gonna
do wines to pair with your kids crappy
behavior well you're up for it huh I'll
do my best okay let's go okay so first
scenario my youngest son is about the
age where it's time to start potty
training there would be days where I'd
walk into a room and just be like
where's the crap coz there's poop in
this room and I realized that my son's
choice pooping spot was the corner of my
closet and that scent just lingers in
your house like potpourri so what I'm
asking is what is the best wine to pair
with my son crapping in the closet well
this is going to be by far the strangest
pairing that I've ever done the first
thing that comes to mind is aromatic
whites and one of them that has the
strongest aroma is called Moscow falero
which is a Greek white wine and the cool
thing about Greece wines nice thank you
smell like rose petals and lemon citrus
I smell [ __ ] blocker am I doing this
right well at some point you can
actually drink up oh we're doing that
that thing right yeah
there you go that's pretty good does
their son really crap in the closet ooh
yeah so next because we haven't gotten
personal enough when parents want to
have a loan time we call it talking you
have to schedule them it's like a huge
ordeal like we will plant the kids on
the couch turn on their favorite TV show
spread out a smorgasbord of snacks and
then it's like all right let's go go go
go go we got 10 minutes like no pressure
the four-year-old now even though we
will lock the door he knows how to
unlock it so is there a wine that can
restart the romance after our son has
walked in on us when I think of romance
like the first thing that comes to mind
is like champagne or sparkling wine
actually one of my favorites is a
franciacorta which is essentially an
Italian champagne we need different
glasses for this well traditionally you
serve a sparkling wine champagne France
champagne pours mm-hmm these are never
used in my Alex and I'm not above
drinking wine out of paper cups wait you
have more than me oh yeah let's switch
hold on mm-hmm maybe like a hint of
almond homeland yeah how do you taste
that how do you like train your tongue
to taste that I mean when my husband
comes home tonight
hello to Matt you're getting lucky next
there's something that happened the
other day I just didn't quite know how
to deal with it we were any elevator is
me and my oldest son who's 4 and he just
talks non-stop to anybody who will
listen
he turns to this woman who gets on the
elevator he looks her dead in the eyes
and is like you know my mom takes big
poops so is there a wine that's gonna
pair with my child over sharing
information with complete strangers this
is getting weird well this one might be
a stretch but I'm gonna just say that
maybe you need to add a little
sweetness in your life I know what I
turn to on days like that
I love Riesling it's got some really
nice qualities to it
traditionally with Riesling you're going
to get a lot of like stone fruit and
minerality I just got it all over mmm
it's like a stronger juice but this is
really delicious and for the record I
don't take big poops get pumped next
every parent has a worst nightmare of
parenting that's something like you're
gonna need a code red wine on hand
that's just like this is it this is what
makes me feel better
like break in case of emergency exactly
like a fire extinguisher what is a wine
that could pair with a parent's worst
nightmare well what would be your worst
nightmare where do I start
arrive at your destination in the car
take the kid out of the car seat smear
of poop all over the car seat bloody
nose is life's the biting phase sleep
training kids handing you their boogers
Caillou what's Caillou oh you don't want
to know okay it sounds to me like you
need something that's very drinkable
something that is maybe easy to pair
with any kind of food do you even say
what I think you're gonna say rose a
rose a rose day all day aching the tub
course
no dear yo I'm chug chug chug chug chug
chug you're a fun last and I'm saving
this for last because it truly broke my
heart I was out here on the couch doing
some work my son was in his room and he
had gotten into my purse and emptied my
makeup bag and took my really expensive
foundation which is the last thing that
I actually spend money on for myself and
he had squeezed the entire bottle out
onto his floor and was finger-painting
in it really so is there a wine
we'll pair with the fact that your kids
ruin every nice thing you have well it
sounds like you're looking for an
expensive line then I think the least
expensive wine I can think of is box
line do you have them no I I mean
nothing against it I just I would never
I feel like I have some I probably do
hold on okay
I have a surprise I don't think you're
supposed to tear the whole thing off
hold on it's like a waterbed should we
just pour it into our mouths or pour it
into a glass I don't see the difference
really oh this looks nice nice color
should we swirl do you want to chug this
one too I don't even want to drink this
one a fancy wine man what are the notes
of this I feel like that's like what the
inside of a glowstick tastes like yeah
no I don't need new foundation do you
want to take this home no I'm good
that's all I got for today I'm Hanna
your friendly neighborhood wine mom just
want to remind everyone that we had a
lot of fun pairing wines with kids
crappy behaviors but we're not promoting
wine as a crutch for motherhood
everything in moderation everything in
good fun thank you so much to Chris for
coming on the show again if you want to
find him in the interwebs at Topher Webb
on twitter twitter i really want to see
your worst parenting nightmares in the
comments share if you've experienced any
of these other things that i've talked
about and as always if you have a topic
that you really want to hear more about
leave that in the comments as well
because i love doing what you guys want
to see till next time
are you jealous we can't burn No